في ضواحي كيف تاوي هذه السيده نوعا اخر من
ضحايا الحرب الدائره
الماضي
[موسيقى]
خرسانيه
واعطتهم فرصه ثانيه للعيش في محيطه
الطبيعيه لكن بالنسبه للحيوانات التي تعيش
في البريه
وبعضهم يموتون ببطء بسبب الخوف دول
استرالشناوي نشره كويس
على البيئه ب 40 مليار دولار والرقم مرشح
لان يتضاعف بعد تحرير اراضينا واحصاء كل
الاضرار
الروسي على اوكرانيا
لكن مع هذا اثر العباده الايكولوجيه ظاهره
جميع الموارد الطبيعيه تضررت دون استثناء
الهواء والتربه والمياه الجوفيه والكائنات
البحريه
بسرعه كبيره بالمساعده الدوليه
مع الطبيعه
التي تقدمه
التي تسببت فيها الحرب الدائره الان لكن
الامر المؤكده ان النظام البيئي هنا يحتاج
الى عقود من الزمن لترميم ما تم تخريبه